not just job Cuts Elon Musk eliminated
Twitter days of rest and work from home
policies last week pushing a 24 7 work
culture if you're a Twitter employee who
has a satisfying work balance life
work-life balance you may not want to
hear what the new boss has to say musk
cut close to 3 700 jobs at Twitter or
half of the workforce via email last
week musk has also removed Twitter's
days of rest monthly days off for
employees to rest and recharge and it's
pushed to implement 24 7 word culture
additionally Bloomberg reported that
musk plans to end the company's remote
work policy and ask remaining employees
to work to return to office full-time
fantastic now watch this next one here
after weeks of media teeth
Nation over musk takeover Twitter sees
explosive user engagement Twitter's
daily user growth hit an all-time high
during the first full week of Elon Musk
owning the platform according to a
company document obtain by The Verge
since musk's dramatic takeover Twitter's
monetizable daily user growth has
accelerated more than 20 percent while
Twitter's largest market the US has
grown even more quickly per the FAQ
Twitter has added more than 15 million
more than 15 million monetizable daily
user not Bots crossing the court of a
billion marks since the end of second
quarter when it stopped reporting
financials as public as a public company
so on one end they're bashing the guy on
the other end it's getting more
engagement than ever before look the
fact that he is just doing this blue
thing for eight bucks it's like look how
many people are doing it I don't know
what the numbers are on that yet but
people wanted to give Twitter money and
Twitter had no mechanism to do it I
think Twitter is going to look
completely 180 different in a year from
now than it looks right now it's going
to look much more like WeChat which is a
Chinese app which there's all sorts of
reasons that we shouldn't be cloning
Chinese apps but that you're going to be
able to do much more within Twitter in
terms of purchases and communities and
all sorts of stuff that's obviously the
route that he's going but he has
unlocked something he has unlocked the
fact that the government was in on it
with the previous guys and Jack Dorsey
should be hauled in front of Congress
again and again I know nothing ever
comes of it when they do it of course
but Jack Dorsey has a lot to pay for
they still have to expose what really
happened with the laptop and who fully
decided all of this stuff and was was a
call put in by the government to Vijaya
got a who is the head of trust and
safety and they there's so much that he
can expose right now and covet and all
hence why Joe Biden is up there going
real well we'll find out and also don't
think don't forget one thing with with
the eight dollars and how he's trying to
monetize he's realizing he can't just
rely on corporate advertisers yeah to
continue you know operating how they
have been because how many advertisers
have already pulled out of Twitter No
someone like 50 has this is definitely
your guys Department more than mine but
has anyone ever bought a company at the
premium that he bought a company at and
then within two weeks fired 75 of the
workforce like is that is there any
comparable to that anywhere past that
normal
it happens all the time with smaller
companies but not at bigger companies
some would you agree with that not at
this time buying buying something at a
premium and then doing something like
this that's not usually the way it works
the way it works is you know it's 1995
and you buy Harley Davidson when it's
really having a tough run but it's a
beautiful brand and it's got products
that can be revived then you remove half
of the people and you restructure it and
then you take off again because it's
Harley Davidson that happened to
Harley-Davidson a couple times in cycle
but it's never a premium where you pay
like this this huge premium for it and
say okay I'm gonna do this also try to
imagine what so many of these employees
were doing on the DL like now that now
that we have some insight and this is
what he really has to expose if he wants
to clean it up and then and then move
the company forward it's like how many
of those employees were reading your DMs
because there's no doubt that they were
100 there's just no doubt that they were
how many of them were making sure that
for example in July of 2021 when I
tweeted out that mandates were coming
and vaccines weren't working and I got
suspended on Twitter was that either the
government that did it or was it an
Insider a Twitter that did it he can now
figure this all out they have logs of
all of this stuff this is not you know
they can't paper shred all of this so
it's like if he just goes in and figures
out who did what when did they do it and
get rid of everybody I mean everybody
there do not hire because of equity
higher because of Competency and and
give everybody what they want it's it's
it he has it in some ways it's a very
easy job because everyone wants him to
succeed except except for like what you
said there don't do not hire because of
equity higher because of Competency and
that's a major theme in America today
right it's very bizarre I don't hire
people based on the color of their skin
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell